Hi. I'm John Green and this is Crash Course
Big History, in which we'll be looking at
the history of, like, everything. I'm talking about
13.8 billion years, from the big bang to now.
I mean, in this series, we are literally
going to attempt to tell you the story of
what Douglas Adams famously called
"life, the universe, and everything."
Mr Green! Mr Green! That's not history. That's
science, and science is for nerds!
Oh, me from the past! Things would be so much
easier for you if you would just accept that
you are, in fact, a nerd! And that's okay!
I mean, look at this picture, dude!
Anyway, academics often describe history as
like, all the stuff that's happened since
we started writing things down, but they only start there
because that's where we have the best information.
And yeah, I think that the advent of writing
was a huge deal, obviously, but as a start
date for history, it's totally arbitrary! It's just a line we
drew in the sand and said "okay, history begins now!"
In Big History, we're gonna start history
when it really starts - at least, we think
- at the creation of the universe, and we're
gonna end that story where it ends - please
let that be after I die! Well, I guess it will definitely
be after I die, just - I want it to be a while after I die!
So we're even gonna terrify traditional historians
by using physics to make some predictions
about the future, and we're gonna end many
trillions and trillions of years from now,
when the universe itself, spoiler alert: dies.
At least, in a manner of speaking.
[Theme Music]
Hey! I'm not John. If you're thinking we look
a little bit the same, that's because we're brothers.
I'm Hank. Anyway, if you wanna learn the 13.8 billion
year history of the universe in the same amount
of time that we usually cover the 238 years of American
history, you're not gonna get the same resolution.
Of course, knowing the names and dates of American history is important, but we just can't do that in Big History.
There are much broader historical questions
in the story of the universe that can only
be explored by zooming out to the ultimate
scale. As you zoom out, you see a lot more
of the picture. The details get a little fuzzy,
but we quickly realize that history is everything.
Cosmology, geology, biology, social sciences,
literature, physics... Everything!
You might think that such a scale would be
filled with way too much detail, but the amount
of detail an answer requires, depends on the
nature of the question. Some questions can
only be explored by zooming out. That is what
Big History does.
Speaking of zoomed out, this is Earthrise,
one of the most famous photographs of all
time. William Anders, an Apollo astronaut,
took it in 1968. From the surface of another
world, we see our planet as a little ball
in space. No borders, no people, no buildings.
Just oceans and clouds and continents being
shined upon by the sun.
That sheer expansion of scale gives me perspective.
It lets me imagine all the complexity of life
on Earth, from the gasoline engine that powered
my trip to the studio, to political instability
in Nepal as part of a thriving, living, teeming
mass of life floating in the emptiness of space.
So what that photograph does for physical
space, Big History aims to do for everything.
I mean, we wanna contextualize all of existence.
We wanna outline the most powerful and important breakthroughs,
the tremendous scale of existence, and how we
know what we know, and why we're sure we know it.
All right, let's go to the Thought Bubble. So
the universe is big. Like, really big. And it's also old.
Like, 13.8 billion years old, which is enough
years that there is no way to actually comprehend it.
So let's just compress that age to 13 years,
small enough that our puny brains can handle it.
On that timescale, the universe would have
begun 13 years ago, in 2001. George W Bush
had just been sworn in as president, most Americans on
the internet were connecting to it with dial-up modems.
Right, so the first stars and galaxies would
have formed 12 years ago, but seven and a
half more years would pass until the Earth
formed, about 4.5 years ago. Move a little
bit up to four years ago - that's when the
first single celled life formed on Earth.
Then leap forward nearly three and a half
more years before the first multi-cellular
organisms in the Cambrian explosion...
What I'm trying to explain is that all complex
life on Earth is a fairly recent development.
Like, on this scale, the dinosaurs went
extinct about three weeks ago --
roughly the last time I changed my Facebook status.
Humans and chimpanzees split from their last
shared ancestor about three days ago!
The first homo sapiens emerged fifty minutes ago,
roughly the last time I checked my email.
We left Africa 26 minutes ago. The American-Indians
reached the Americas 6 minutes ago --
roughly the last time I checked my Twitter.
We invented agriculture 5 minutes ago. Ancient
Egypt? 3 minutes ago! The Black Death? 24
seconds ago. The Industrial Revolution - 6
seconds. World War One, 2 seconds. The Cold
War, th e first man on the moon, your birth, the internet,
the Big Mac? All within the last second.
But in many other ways, complex life and humanity
are exceptional. Thanks, Thought Bubble!
Also exceptional, by the way, the Mongols!
[Mongoltage]
Okay, let's begin at the beginning! The big
bang!
Hank, wait a second! Woah, woah, woah, woah,
woah. I- I don't understand how we know that
the big bang is really the beginning. Like,
what happened before the big bang?
Well. Okay. Uh... Theoretical physicists say
that space and time are not two different
things. They are two expressions of one thing
- space-time. And space-time was created by
the big bang, thus time didn't exist before
the big bang, so it doesn't make much sense
to ask what happened before it. There was
no "then", then!
Of course, this, like many ideas in cosmology,
doesn't really make any sense to our puny
human brains. It's largely beyond our comprehension,
rather like explaining color to a blind person.
We know that it's true because the math works
and it explains our observations so elegantly,
but it's so far outside of how we directly
perceive the world, that I don't think it's
something even the most genius physicists
are able to imagine.
But yeah, if you're gonna do a chronological
study of the universe, the creation of time
is probably a pretty good place to start the
story.
So the big bang wasn't something that happened
inside the universe, nor did it expand into
some kind of void. It was literally the moment
when both time and space were created. The
thing that was banging was the universe itself.
It was expanding from an unimaginably tiny
point to an unimaginably large universe, unimaginably
quickly.
Unimaginable is basically the subtitle to
the story of the big bang, but then again,
it's also kind of the subtitle to everything
else in big history.
I mean, I can only do this occasionally, but
sometimes you look outside and you're like,
"Oh, my goodness! This is nuts! How did we get trees?"
Needless to say, we will be talking about that.
Anyway, the universe is a hard worker, and
it got most of the heavy lifting done in those
first few seconds. For comparison, it takes
me about twenty minutes after I wake up for
me to even get myself into a standing position.
But the universe is somewhat more efficient.
In the barest fraction of the first second,
the universe inflated from something many,
many, many times smaller than an atom to about
the size of a grapefruit. Like, think of it
this way: in much less than a blink of an
eye, if it'd originally been the size of a
tennis ball, it would have inflated to over
ninety billion light-years across.
This inflation theory has been well backed-up
by mathematics for a long time now, but it
has recently received some staggering new
support from the BICEP project at the South
Pole, which sadly has nothing to do with my
guns.
Ten seconds after the big bang, the universe
had expanded enough that the normal rules
of the universe, with atomic forces and gravity
and electromagnetism that we know and love
today, were already in charge. All of the
anti-matter created in the big bang had combined
with matter and annihilated itself, leaving
behind only one billionth of the matter created
in the big bang, and that billionth is everything!
And I mean everything. Every grain of sand,
every blueberry you will ever eat, every star
that you will ever see - everything!
We've already tried to understand how big a billion is,
but just pause to think about that - everything!
Everything! Is one billionth of the matter
created in the big bang. [Explosion sound]
The first law of thermodynamics is that matter
and energy cannot be created or destroyed.
Everything we have now, we had then. The matter
that makes up your body right now has been
around since those moments 13.8 billion years
ago. It's simply changed form.
After just three minutes, the universe was
cool enough that the nuclei of atoms started
forming - just hydrogen and helium back then,
the two simplest elements - keep those two
in mind, however, because it turns out, if
you take a bunch of hydrogen and you wait
like, several billion years, you might just
grow yourself some humans!
Let's remember: at this time, the universe
was still very, very hot. I don't wanna use
the word unimaginable too often, but it was
unimaginably hot!
The universe remained like an uber-hot sea
dominated by radiation, but then luckily,
it simmered down to a balmy 5,000 degrees
Fahrenheit about 380 thousand years after
the big bang, allowing matter and radiation
to separate.
And remember, matter is just a more congealed
form of energy. I mean, you are a somewhat
firm bag of energy. In my case, not that firm.
So anyway, at 5,000 degrees Fahrenheit, radiation
was finally able to move freely through the
universe, and we see that radiation today
as the end of the Dark Ages that followed
the big bang, and the beginning of a brilliant
flash that we call Cosmic Background Radiation,
which is a great name for a band.
Physicists call it the fingerprint of the
universe and it's one of the most important
pieces of historical evidence we have for
the big bang, because CBR is everywhere.
Tune your radio to a frequency that doesn't
have a station - a portion of the static you
hear is actually that cosmic background radiation
being picked up by your radio. So you can
literally hear the universe in its infancy!
Sometimes it can be tricky to know what's
true, especially when we're talking about
stuff that happened so far in the distant
past. That is why we created science, that
elegant system for sorting out the facts from
the fertilizer.
So just using your limited human senses, you
might come to the same conclusion as 19th
century scientists, that the universe is static,
eternal and infinite... But then, using our
minds, if the universe is infinite and contains
infinite stars and it has always existed,
then the night sky, and the day-time sky for
that matter, would literally be filled with
stars - so much that day and night would be
indistinguishable! This is clearly not the
case, so something must be amiss.
The universe must either be not static, not
infinite or not eternal. So which is it? You
know how when an ambulance drives towards
you, the sound-waves are compressed and the
siren sounds higher pitched, and as it speeds
away, the waves are stretched out and the
pitch is lower? It's the Doppler effect.
Well, here's another name you've heard. Edwin
Hubble. He realized that light does the same
thing. Galaxies and stars moving away from
us have their light stretched out, making
it more red, and stars moving toward us have
their light compressed, making it more blue.
Combined with the work of Henrietta Leavitt,
which allowed us to accurately estimate how
far away stars are, Hubble was able to determine that
stars, on the whole, are flying away from each other.
He discovered that the most remote objects
in the sky were all red-shifted and were actually
other galaxies beyond the milky way, moving
away from us. From here, he built upon the
work of Belgian Catholic priest Georges Lemaitre,
who hypothesized that the universe began at
a single point. Big bang cosmologists wanted
proof though. They knew that the amount of
radiation released by the big bang would be
massive, and they wanted to see it.
It wasn't until the 1960s that it was found
accidentally, by two guys working on an antenna
at Bell Laboratories in New Jersey. They were
trying to eliminate all the background noise
from an extremely sensitive radio antenna, but they
found this faint hum coming from every direction.
They tried everything they could to get rid
of it, including murdering the pigeons that
kept pooping on the antenna - kinda sad, but
those pigeons - they gave their lives for
one of the most profound discoveries in modern
science. A conversation with a local radio
astronomer lead them to show their findings
to an astronomer at Princeton, who confirmed
the existence of what had been predicted for
years.
The final piece of that big bang puzzle is
that we can see it. Light has a speed. When
we look at the sun, we're seeing the light
that left it eight minutes ago, but if we
look at something that's 13.8 billion light-years
away, we're seeing the stuff that happened
13.8 billion years ago! That radiation has been
traveling since the very beginning of the universe.
Not only can we tell very clearly that there
was just nothing there before that, we can
now study that radiation to learn the sequence
of events of the big bang. We can also see
that the chemical composition of the early
universe is what we'd expect to see - a lot
of hydrogen, a lot of helium and a tiny pinch
of lithium. The rest of the periodic table
had to wait for the fiery furnaces and the
bellies of stars to be created.
But more on that, next episode!
As far as we've come in the past century in
crafting a history of the universe, there
are still many things cosmologists have yet
to discover. For instance, the universe behaves
as if there's a bunch of matter in it that
we can't see or detect. Galaxies' gravitation
is affected by this matter, but it's otherwise
completely invisible to us. Physicists call
it dark matter, but we have no idea what it
is! But as in any historical endeavor, new
discoveries will alter the story in future
years, so expect the big histories of ten
or twenty years from now to look very different
from today's.
But this isn't discouraging, because like,
knowing everything would be boring!
There's a lot left to discover, and at the current
pace of scientific inquiry, many of those
amazing discoveries will await us in our lifetime!
Or at least in your lifetime.
Whether it be World War Two or the life of
Abe Lincoln, all histories ultimately start
with the big bang. Yeah, it would be silly
to start your typical World War Two textbook
with the big bang, but it would be about a
hundred trillion, trillion times more ridiculous
to say the big bang - the mother of all historical
events - was not history.
And that's why big history reaches into the
lives of every person on this tiny speck of
dust we call home, regardless of nation, class
or creed, and forms our common story.
See you next time!